scum City president and population me hi
guys answers helping do not know now you
know your life is different now it is
the end of July so it's time for a July
favorites video I didn't do a June
favorites video but that doesn't change
any of the things that are in this video
also apparently one of my favorite
things are run-on sentences all to a
great start and give me the same caveat
I give all my favorite videos maybe it's
very likely that most if not all of this
stuff has been in a previous favorites
video so my apologies if I have doubled
up and that bothers you I'm here to try
not to bother you or to bother you in a
way that makes you better
let's get a little stressed before we
get into favorites I don't know why they
should be good things that I like I've
changed my world for the better
who knows run on sentences favorites
please can't say yeah yeah say yeah say
yeah I mean these are flecked now's the
time to reflect ha ha ha
these are sunglasses bikie or k qu a why
not tell Asher how you say it but I'm
sure someone out there believes that
they have a definitive answer to that
question and we'll leave it in the
comments down below these are an
Australian brand of sunglasses that I
have like 5 or 6 pairs of now and I just
got these because I'm pretty sure I was
very hungover and I decided that I
should be rewarded so I ordered myself
like three pairs sunglasses from their
website and I forgot about them and
that's always fun because it's like a
surprise treasure
freebie itself gave to your future self
but your future self can really do
anything to deserve it
there ABA ters and they have this kind
of rose gold pink lens things to them I
look like a snapchat filter and then the
fun thing is people get annoyed when you
wear these if you're sitting across from
them at like brunch or just in life
because it's like two mirrors and they
get distracted looking at their own face
little do they know I've been doing that
for nine years cute next what is next
yeah okay I'll say yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah this is the product that
it has absolutely 1000% for sure been in
previous multiple favorites videos its
cooperate if you know me you know I love
this stuff and poopourri the brand knows
I love this stuff we have some
communication on Twitter poopourri is
the spray before you go toilet spray so
a [ __ ] don't stink as bad as it used to
this is a sense called tropical hibiscus
and it's awesome I've gotten too used to
the sense that I currently have in my
household so I don't think that it
smells nice I just immediately associate
that smell with [ __ ] so this is a set I
haven't tried before and it's delightful
it does smell like a tropical hibiscus
and it's up to 200 uses so depending on
how irritable your bowels are this
should last you a decent amount of time
cute next yeah can't say you can say yes
say yeah I am pretty certain this has
also been in a favorite video before I'm
sorry
this is maybelline superstay better skin
skin transforming foundation it's just
or foundation by Maybelline and I really
really like it this is in the number 20
classic ivory but I also bought 25 which
is a classic nude and then I combined
them
I don't know what my skin tone color is
I just wear high neck things and hope no
one notices that these are two different
colors this one I have noticed is very
full coverage it's got SPF 15
it the sunscreen that barely does
anything like me it's just a skin
transforming foundation and I do think
it does kind of the more if it's on your
skin really just like set into it and
transforms to your skin fill out just
bullshitting I have no idea I just like
it and it's cheap and it's got a pump
top which is very helpful in keeping it
as non messy as possible even though
it's insistent gummed up real good real
fast real hard by me cute yeah yeah can
you see yeah yeah yeah hey I'll see ya
this is a mm-hmm this is a bathing suit
that I featured in another video and the
big that sexy bathing suit Tryon Hall to
watch it if you haven't it's sexy her
than this video this is a bathing suit
from Cup she which I learned about via
Meghan drinks in her bathing suit Tryon
video go watch it it's pretty great and
she tried this bathing suit on in her
video and I thought it was so funny that
I went and I bought it for myself and I
loved it because it's so dumb you have a
sad-looking lion on your kik sad-looking
line on your cooter and thus bad looking
lying on your booty let's go it's
determined instead of sad that makes it
better this is super cheap it was like
$12 it fits me pretty well and I think
it's really cute yes yeah KSP yeah yes
yeah yes yeah this is stupid
and also this pen is pretty dumb hahaha
just kidding
everything I'm doing here is purposeful
and helpful this is a pen marker
scenario thing that I got in a little
anime drawing kit from Walmart I went
camping recently and we thought that
Walmart to kind of load up on all the
things that we might need and I saw this
little notebook with all these pens and
pencils for drawing or sketching but I
wanted to use it for coming up with
genius content is and it came with these
markers it looks like a liquid eyeliner
but don't I mean
if you're in a pinch maybe he'll prove
McCullar scholar brush tip point what
it's just a brush tip marker and I like
it very much it works very well it
doesn't seep through on the paper in the
notebooks or something really cathartic
about it question
[Music]
Wow so satisfying - next back and say
hey I'll see ya see ya this is a bandana
of Glacier National Park won one of my
favorites for this month is this actual
bandana and - one of my other favorites
is Glacier National Park like I said I
just like camping last week if you
follow me on social media you saw too
much of it I'm sure I'm sorry
everywhere you look was just pretty
nature for an Internet girl to go
outside and do not feel afraid but
instead appreciate her surroundings it
had to be pretty [ __ ] beautiful
I'd be like a very Coachella park ranger
this is like SVA meets MapQuest cute yes
me yes ane I'll say hey you see these
are leggings that I'm pretty sure I've
also been in a favorites video before I
was traveling I was hoping to finish a
thought at some point I was traveling
before New Year's and doing some more
outdoor hiking stuff and before I left I
went by Target just to get myself some
more leggings they do it outside it
might be cold and I got these these are
the champion brands legging and they're
awesome they fit really well they're
super long I've really long legs so
that's awesome
and then the best part is they have
[ __ ] pockets on the side this is such
a first world problem but they're now
first world solutions its leggings with
pockets I got through back in December
so I don't know if they're still at
Target so how helpful is that as well
cute okay guys I sit for this favorites
video if you liked it give this video a
thumbs up and don't forget to click
subscribe to this YouTube channel put
that little Bell notification thing on
because I make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometimes consistently
inconsistent this is very trendy I don't
know next can you see a cute kitty you
can't see it right now but you will be
able to see it on August 14th since I
heart food had a hearts new cooking show
Food Show food travel show on the Food
Network so I just want to do guys to
know in case you did it already to mark
your calendars for August 14th at 10
p.m. 10 p.m. so I'm referring to her own
Instagram so that I don't [ __ ] up this
information
because I care about my friends and
their projects